hello everyone welcome to part six in
our series on supervised sentiment
analysis this screencast is going to
cover two important methods in this
space hyperparameter search and
classifier comparisons
so let's begin with hyper parameter
search and first i'll just offer the
rationale
let's say that the parameters of a model
are those whose values are learned as
part of optimizing the model itself so
for the classifiers we've been studying
the parameters are really just the
weights that you learn on each of the
individual features
and those are the things that are
directly targeted by the optimization
process
the parameters of a model are typically
pretty crisply defined because they kind
of follow from the structure
mathematically of the model under
investigation
much more diffuse are the hyper
parameters we can say the hyper
parameters of a model are any settings
that are outside of the optimization
process mentioned in one so examples
from models we've seen our glove and lsa
have that dimensionality setting
the model itself gives you no guidance
about what to choose for the
dimensionality
and the dimensionality is not selected
as part of the optimization of the model
itself you have to choose it via some
external mechanism making it a hyper
parameter
and glove actually has two other
additional prominent hyper parameters
xmax and alpha again those are not
optimized by the model you have to
select them via some external mechanism
and for the classifiers that we've been
studying you know we have regularization
terms those are classic hyper parameters
if you have a deep classifier then the
hidden dimensionalities in the model
could also be considered hyper
parameters learning rates um you know
any core feature of the optimization
method itself could be considered hyper
parameters and even things that might be
considered kind of architectural like
the activation function in the deep
classifier you might think of it as kind
of an intrinsic part of the model that
you're evaluating but since it's an easy
choice point for us at this point you'll
be tempted to explore a few different
options for that particular
architectural choice and in that way it
could become a hyper parameter and at
this point even the optimization methods
could also emerge as a hyper parameter
that you would like to do search over
and so forth and so on you should
probably take a fairly expansive view of
what the hyper parameters of your model
are if you can now here's the crux of
the argument hyper parameter
optimization is crucial to building a
persuasive argument fundamentally for
any kind of comparison we make we want
to put every model in its very best
light
we could take it for granted that for
any sufficiently complicated model
there's some setting of its hyper
parameters that's kind of degenerate and
would make the model look very bad
and so you certainly wouldn't want to do
any comparisons against that really
problematic set of choices rather what
we want to do is say let's put all the
models in their best light by choosing
optimal hyper parameters for them to the
best of our ability and then we can say
that one model is better than the other
if it emerges victorious in that very
rigorous
setting
and the final thing i'll say about this
methodologically is that of course all
hyperparameter tuning must be done only
on train and development data you
consider you can consider that all fair
game in terms of using it however you
want to choose the optimal hyper
parameters but once that choice is set
it is fixed and those are the parameters
that you use at test time and that is
the fundamental evaluation that you
would use for any kind of model
comparison and at no point should you be
tuning these hyper parameters on the
test data itself that would be
completely illegitimate
i hope we've made it really easy to do
this kind of hyper parameter search in
the context of the work you're doing for
supervised sentiment analysis here are
some code snippets that show how that
can happen
i load in my libraries i have a pointer
to our sentiment data and here i have a
fixed feature function which is just a
unigram steamer feature function
the change happens inside the model
wrapper
whereas before essentially all we did is
set up a logistic regression model and
then call its fit method
here we set up that model but also
established a grid of hyper parameters
these are different choice points for
this logistic regression model like
whether or not i have a bias term
the value of the regularization
parameter and even the algorithm used
for regularization itself l1 or l2
the model will explore the full grid of
these options it's going to do five-fold
cross-validation so test one each five
times on different splits of the data
and in that very long search process it
will find what it takes to be the best
setting of all of these hyper parameters
of all the combinations that can
logically be
set
and that is the model that we finally
return here right so now you can see the
value of having a wrapper around these
fit methods because then i could do all
of this extra work without changing the
interface to sst experiment at all the
experiments look just as they did in the
previous mode it's just that they will
take a lot longer because you are
running dozens and dozens of experiments
as part of this exhaustive search of all
the possible settings
okay r2 is classifier comparison let's
again begin with the rationale suppose
you've assessed a baseline model b
and your favorite model m and your
chosen assessment metric favors m right
and this seems like a little victory for
you but you should still ask yourself is
m really better right now if the
difference between b and m is clearly of
practical significance then you might
not need to do anything beyond
presenting the numbers right if each one
of your classification decisions
corresponds to something really
important in the world and your
classifier makes thousands more good
predictions than the other model that
might be enough for the argument but
even in that situation you might ask
whether there's variation in how these
two models b and m perform did you just
get lucky when you saw what looked like
a practical difference and with minor
changes to the initialization of
something you would see very different
outcomes
if the answer is possibly yes then you
might still want to do some kind of
classifier comparison
now there's this nice paper by dempshark
2006 that advises using the wilcoxon
signed rank test for situations in which
you can afford to repeatedly assess your
two models b m on different train test
splits right and we'll talk and later in
the term about the precise rationale for
this but the idea is just that you would
do a lot of experiments on slightly
different views of your data and kind of
average across them to get a sense for
whether the two for how the two models
compare with each other
in situations where you can't repeatedly
assess b m
mars test is a reasonable alternative it
operates on the confusion matrices
produced by the two models testing the
null hypothesis that the two models have
the same error rate
the reason you might opt for mcneemar's
test is for example if you're doing a
deep learning experiment where all the
models take a few weeks to optimize then
of course you can't probably afford to
do dozens and dozens of experiments with
each one so you might be compelled to
use mcnee mars based on one single run
of the two models it's a much weaker
argument because of course precisely the
point is that we might see variation
across different runs and mcnee mars is
not really going to grapple with that in
the way that the wilcoxon sign right
test will
but this is arguably better than nothing
in most situations so you might default
to mcnee mars
if the wilcoxon is too expensive
and let me just show you how easy this
can be in the context of our code base
so my by way of illustration what we're
essentially going to do is compare
logistic regression and naive bayes i
encourage you when you're doing these
comparisons to have only one point of
variation so we're going to fix the data
and we're going to fix the feature
function and compare only the model
architectures
you could separately say i'm going to
have a single fixed model like logistic
regression and explore a few different
feature functions
but i would advise against exploring two
different feature functions as combined
with two different models because when
you observe differences in the end you
won't be sure whether that was caused by
the model choice or by the feature
functions we want to kind of isolate
these things and do systematic
comparisons
so here i'm going to do a systematic
comparison of logistic regression and
naive bayes on the sst using the
wilcoxon test and here's the setup the
function is sst compare models
i point it to my training data
you can have two feature functions but
in that case you should have just one
model wrapper here i've got one feature
function used for both models and i'll
have these two different wrappers
corresponding to the evaluation that i
want to do of those two model classes
i'm going to use the wilcoxon as advised
i'll do 10 trials of each
on the train size of 70 of the data and
as always in this setting i'll use the
macro f1 as my score
so what this will do internally is run
10 experiments on different train test
splits for each one of these models that
gives us a score vector
uh 10 you know 10 numbers for each model
and then what the wilcoxon is doing is
comparing whether the or make assessing
whether the means of those two score
vectors are statistically significantly
different and here it looks like we have
some evidence that we can reject the
null hypothesis that these models are
identical
which is presumably the argument that we
were trying to build
now of course that's very expensive
because we had to run 20 experiments in
this situation and of course you could
run many more if you were also doing
hyper parameter tuning as part of your
experimental workflow
so in situations where you can't afford
to do something that involves so many
experiments as i said you could default
to make new mars
that is included in utils.mcneimar
and the return values of ssd experiment
will give you all the information you
need essentially for mcneemars you need
the actual gold vector of labels and
then the two vectors of predictions for
each one of your experiments so that's a
simple alternative in the situation in
which wilcoxon was just too expensive